an overwhelmingly confusing story
jarring special effects or just a studio
too afraid to Market it here's why David
Lynch's Dune became a certified box
office bomb director dannyville nerves
Dune proved to be a Bonafide hit the
film received solid reviews from critics
and the 402 million dollar Global box
office Hall returned by the time it left
theaters is no small Feast considering
it was released during the covid-19
pandemic a big budget Blockbuster did so
well that fans and no doubt Studio execs
are eagerly awaiting the next
installment on one hand that might not
be too much of a surprise the movie is
after all adapted from one of the best
loved sci-fi novels of all time it's a
Blockbuster on a massive scale featuring
Cutting Edge effects and a cast full of
Talent on the other hand the Dune has a
well-earned reputation as being an
immensely challenging book to bring to
the big screen the avant-garde filmmaker
Alejandro yoderovsky famously attempted
to mount a production in the 1970s now
that version never came to fruition and
it wasn't until 1984 that a big budget
feature film adaptation arrived when it
did though it didn't exactly bring the
spice that fans of the novel might have
been hoping for he who can
you can spice
1984 version of Doom was a third feature
film directed by David Lynch and it
boasted a huge budget and a cast of
entertainment's biggest stars at the
time despite all that however the movie
was also a massive box office flop when
Dune hit theaters in 1984 it raid the
nearly 31 million dollars at the global
box office against a 40 million dollar
budget thus cementing its reputation as
a bomb and the world is not always a
clear and easy explanation for why some
movies fail at the box office in the
case of Dune it seems pretty obvious the
negative press of film got played a
significant role Dune did not fare well
with critics when it was released in a
one star review from the time of the
movie's release Roger Ebert wrote this
movie is a real mess an incomprehensible
ugly unstructured pointless Excursion
into the Mercury Realms of one of the
most confusing screenplays of all time
for many critics the novels epic scope
and intricate World building are
translated to a film that was confusing
frustrating and dumb rights not
enjoyable in her review for the New York
Times Janet Maslin called the movie's
narrative perilously overloaded and
added about the story it is presented
here much too solemnly to leave room for
the wit or agility that could have made
it fun
is near me find her from me
of course it takes more than just poor
Word of Mouth to make a film struggle in
the financial department if a studio
once could be moviegoers to check out a
new feature instead feature has to be
promoted in some form or fashion to get
the masses interested sure Doom receives
trailers and posters to jump up some
hype but even one of the actors in the
film has noted that the casting crew
didn't do much press work ahead of its
release a 2021 deadline interview with
Francesca Anis who played lady Jessica
in David Lynch's Dune illuminates this
potential contributing factor to the
film's failure when asked about what
kind of press he did for the film The
actor gave a pretty telling response
saying I don't remember any huge junkets
or anything they must have known way
before it came out that it was in
trouble they might have thought they
spent enough money on it already it
looks like the classic combination of
bad reviews and for marketing turned
David Lynch's Dune into a cinematic
Stone burner although it's built up a
proper cult following in the years since
its release
foreign